locataires
[musique]
nous l'avons
a été installé ici avec nous et les tapis étaient posés
les rayures étaient nombreuses dans les couloirs des courts
les miroirs étaient en très bon état
ce n'était pas cool
[musique]
oh je ne m'en souviens pas
Je vois
tout ce que tu ne frappes pas pendant que nous vivons encore
la fin du 19ème siècle, même si dans la cour il semble y avoir
vingt-et-unième siècle
presque tout nous sommes libres et le paysage
[musique]
dis-moi qu'il y a deux camps seuls
crois que cet endroit est notre urbain
bidonvilles qui doivent être démolis et
cet endroit pour construire une résidence moderne
d'autres complexes comme je pense
qu'il s'agit d'un objet architectural unique
il faut le sauvegarder
restaurer et ainsi de suite
[musique]
J'ai choisi ce site parce qu'il
un endroit incroyable
une énergie incroyable, on a le sentiment que
ici, c'est le moment d'une manière incroyable
arrêté
[musique]
Et
d'accord
[musique]